Chứ này ngày 6,5 năm, không ăn tình đồng này đã tổ chức buổi hợp báo về cái
có điều tra bán đầu của vụ án đặc biệt nghiêm trong sẻ ra tại sả đất nhau.
Đồng này, tại buổi họ, thưa tương mến đứa hai, giả nước không ăn tình đồng này
cho biết lực lượng lượng trức năng đặc hi động hơn năm trong khán bộ,
chỉ nghĩ để chuyến bắt nghi phạm lên sĩ tung, 3-3 tuổi, 1 phương phúc mình, tình đồng này,
chỉ sâu năm may sáo dự kể từ khi phát hiện vụ việc,
mi phạm đã bị bắt khi đang trên đường lên chốn.
Khi kỏ điều tra bán đầu cho thấy đồng cơ gây án là dịch nguyết cơ tài sản,
khám xét nơi ở của đối tượng này, các quan công an thu dữ một khẩu xuống,
làm trong năm mi viên đạn chưa bán vả năm 2020,
chưa đêm cơ án, tụng đại ở nấp tại đổi phi trước nhà nạn nhân để thăm sóc.
Công an xa định đối tự trình bị kỹ lưỡng nhằm chết giấu hành vi phạm tội.
Chưa có thông tin nào cho thấy nghi phạm nghiêm,
gì người vì làm những vụ trong game như một số thông tin làm chuyện trên mạng sóh hội.
Công an cho biết đối tự trị có một sét đạn chơi game khi còn học cấp bà,
tình trạng su khỏe và tâm lý khổ đối tượng mình thường không có số hiệu bất ông.
Trong quá trình đối trà, lực lượng trực năng phụ thật hơn năm 2019 có giả trị từ vư dân,
có phần quan trọng giúp nhân trọng phán.
Thông tin thêm tại buổi hợp báo về kỹ quả đối trà,
thưa tưởng nguyễn đứa khải cho biết,
hình cơ quan cảy ra đối trà công an tình đã giá quy định khởi tổ vụ án,
khởi tổ bị cân để đối trà về hành viên dưới,
hình nhà đối tượng này có nhiều vật sự như dây mồ đàn dính bún đất đó,
có nhiều điểm Trung Quốc với các vật sự tụ được ở bên hệ trường buạn.
Một số nhân trình xác định đã triếp tế các đối tượng này gần hệ trường buạn.
Dự trình các tại liệu, chính cứu thập trong quả trình đều tra,
quay cùng đối tượng đã thử hình tòan bộ hành vi phản tội.
Thưa đó, cơ quan công an xác định xác người mừng hai tháng bởi,
tùng đón xe khách từ tình lâm đồng về thành phố chiming,
xuống xác tại diễn đón xe biết đối dịch công việc suy tiến thuộc phường liệu Trung.
Tại đây, tùng tức tục đón xe biết đến biển xe mình đông
và mua về xe khách đến định bản xác đất nhau,
tình đông này rồi xa đó thuê xe ông vào khu vực kênh nhà nạn nhân để vẻ án.
Đến xác người mừng ba tháng mười, xóc khi về án,
tùng đi bộ ra khu vực xác bong bò và đón xe ông về nhà ở phương phương
phương bình cho đến lúc bị lực công an phát hiện,
và sự ước vào chương mềm năng tháng người.
Hết lực lượng chức năng đăng tích tục mở giọc đuổi trà.